Припинення війни та повернення Криму -
одні з ключових викликів, які доведеться долати новому президенту України.
Майже всі кандидати обіцяють повернення територій дипломатичним шляхом.
Щоправда, конкретики в їхніх програмах небагато, як і кардинально нових пропозицій.
Лідер перегонів виключає можливість військового звільнення окупованих територій.
На самому початку президентської кампанії Володимир Зеленський заявив,
що мінські угоди не працюють, і наголошував, що з Росією щодо Донбасу доведеться домовлятися.
Доведеться говорити. Ну, доведеться говорити.
Ми хочемо, не хочемо, через себе, хоч з чортом лисим готовий домовитися,
аби не вмирала жодна людина.
Проте із наближенням виборів риторика Зеленського дещо змінилася.
Тепер він заявляє, що для розв’язання конфлікту на Донбасі
слід спиратися на мінські домовленості, але процес треба трансформувати,
додавши до нього представників США та Великобританії.
Водночас повернути Крим, на думку шоумена, вдасться…
... лише після того, як зміниться влада в Росії.
Тим часом, чинний президент України
обіцяє повернути Крим вже після обрання його на другий термін.
Ні на які торги,
ні на які підкилимні домовленості Україна ніколи не піде.
І Крим буде повернуто Україні.
Ми зробимо все можливе  для того, щоб це було зроблено якнайшвидше,
одразу ж після президентських виборів.
Так само після виборів Порошенко розраховує
і на прогрес у питанні введення миротворців ООН на окупованому Донбасі.
Щоправда, не конкретизує, які структури і країни мають увійти до складу місії,
хоча це - один із каменів спотикання на переговорах про такі перспективи.
На початку першої каденції Петро Порошенко вже обіцяв, що АТО триватиме "години, а не місяці".
На відміну від свого давнього опонента Петра Порошенка,
Юлія Тимошенко таких сміливих обіцянок щодо повернення Криму не дає.
Крим ми не зможемо повернути зразу, але ми нікому не дозволимо звикнути до питання,
що Крим неукраїнський, і ми нікому не дозволимо
малювати на чужих мапах наш Крим як свою територію.
Загалом у своїй передвиборній програмі Тимошенко пропонує повертати окуповані території
військово-дипломатичним шляхом.
Для цього вона обіцяє модернізувати армію за стандартами НАТО
і домагатися колективних заходів з примусу агресора до миру.
Переговори, як переконана Тимошенко,
мають відбуватися на основі Будапештського меморандуму.
Іще один лідер президентських перегонів переконаний:
повертати окуповані території на Донбасі слід, цитую, "дипломатичними, воєнними,
економічними та санкційними засобами спільно із зарубіжними партнерами".
Причому для цього, на переконання Гриценка, достатньо одного президентського терміну.
Хижаки поїдають слабших, слабшим диктують.
Ми повинні стати сильними, тільки тоді ми можемо говорити про реальне повернення,
причому за 5 років це реально, окупованих територій і далі наступний етап - Криму.
Втім, щодо повернення півострова кандидат конкретних обіцянок не дає.
Адже, як і Зеленський, вважає,
що деокупація Криму можлива тільки, коли Путін втратить владу в Росії.
Єдиний проросійський кандидат серед тих, хто має найбільші шанси на перемогу,
обіцяє припинити конфлікт на Донбасі виключно мирним шляхом.
Причому задля миру в Україні та повернення окупованих територій
під її юрисдикцію Юрій Бойко готовий домовлятися з усіма сторонами конфлікту.
Як результат, на думку колишнього регіонала,
мають бути напрацьовані пропозиції, які слід винести на референдум...
І сказати: громадяни України, ми пропонуємо такий сценарій, так чи ні?
Якщо так, то ми рухаємося до підписання мирного договору
і проведення далі політичним шляхом повернення територій, людей,
відновлення контролю за кордоном, відновлення влади на цих територіях української.
Водночас про звільнення захопленого Росією Криму у виборчій програмі Бойка - немає ані слова.